[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir was
schnelles einfaches und leckeres bzw
schokolade ist wir machen schoko bomben
jetzt fragt ihr euch ist geknackt jetzt
fragt ihr euch was schokolade sind
schoko bomben sind einfach kleine feine
kügelchen die in den extrem schokoladig
sind und von außen so eine schöne wien
ich das so eine besondere optik war
schwieriges wort schwieriges war nicht
nicht marmoriert sowie auf geplant
leute lasst euch überraschen das rezept
das genial hat er im interview
manchmal fehlen einfach die worte so
toll sind die rezepte
also ich stehe jetzt ja meiner
küchenmaschine ihr könnt eure
handrührgerät finden mit dem schneebesen
geht es nicht so einfach verlassen
relativ festtag ist den wir jetzt machen
und da gebe ich jetzt meine zutaten
reine zutaten stehen in meinen videos
immer in der video beschreibung dann ist
es für sie für euch einfach zu scream
schotten und einkaufen zu gehen sehr
sehr schwere geburt ich dachte wir sind
für steven zu tagen gibt es hier schon
mal die eier rein und dann das öl
[Musik]
und jetzt ganz kurz verrühren und dann
mehl zucker kakao und backpulver dazu
geben
[Musik]
und die zutaten jetzt nur so lange
miteinander verrühren bis sie sich
verbunden haben also ihr müsst jetzt
nicht irgendwie die eier aufschlagen
oder irgendwas schaumig schlagen das ist
jetzt hier nicht gefordert und wenn sich
der teig so aus also der ist relativ
fest und auch ein bisschen klebrig und
den gebe ich jetzt in den kühlschrank
für circa eineinhalb stellen das habe
ich schon vorbereitet wenn ich konnte
mich gut vorbereiten wir können dafür
nachher die doppelte menge essen auch
gut also ich habe mir den vorbereiteten
genügen so wie ich die hier vorbereitet
habe das zeige ich euch jetzt also der
teig ist jetzt nach der kühl zeit
deutlich fester also klebt jetzt nicht
mehr seinen händen und ich nehme mir
immer so einen halben teelöffel also
wirklich nicht viel die gehen jetzt noch
ein bisschen aufrufen einfach zu einer
kugel zusammen rollen die sieht dann so
aus geht auch ganz schnell
und die gibt ihr dann einfach in
puderzucker also hier drin wälzen und
dann aufs mit backpapier ausgelegtes
backblech geben so fertig
[Musik]
jetzt werden die schoko bomben gebacken
ganz ganz wichtig den ofen vorheizen auf
180 grad ober unterhitze dann brauchen
sie echt nur so acht bis zehn minuten
also ich sage mal gerne circa angaben
weil jeder offenbar anders und sie zu
dass er sie nicht zu lange drin dass die
dürfen im kern noch so ein bisschen
fertig sein und dann zeige ich euch wie
die optik nach dem backen aussieht jetzt
habe ich gerade einmal auf instagram
gefragt wie ich denn diese köstlichkeit
noch nennen kann er sich in schokobraun
ganz passen gerade kam ein super
forscher ein schoko wäldchen weil es
außen ja weiß ist und so ein bisschen
aussieht wie eine wolke ich richtig gute
idee was sagt ihr denn hat mir noch
andere namensvorschläge brauchen passt
aber in verstecken die sehr sehr gut
jetzt zum tee oder zum kaffee oder ist
nicht die einfach so oder was ich auch
genial finde
nehmt euch eine blechdose legt sie schön
rein und dann einfach verschenken
richtig süß also ich dort will er auf
jeden fall
und dann sagt seine ehrliche meinung
kein blatt vor den mund nehmen und
wollte ich mir die show korrekt
ja ich sag ja das mag ich ja voll waren
ihr habt die besten vorschläge wie die
faust aufs auge
ich könnte mir jetzt auch ein und euch
ganz viel freude beim nachbacken hier
unten wie gesagt in der video
beschreibung schreibe ich euch gramm
genau die mengenangaben und dann warte
ich nur noch auf eure fotos jeden posten
könnt mit dem hashtag des kitsches her
okay okay haben wir jetzt machen wir
noch die fotos und dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten rezept video charts einmal
das andere noch zeigen
jetzt da das spricht bände
so jetzt lassen wir euch in ruhe und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]